there's gonna be haters it's gonna
happen it's not possible for it not to
happen
and the greater the risk that you're
taking in your content in your life and
who you declare yourself to be publicly
the more hate there will be
period
is this the easiest time in the world to
find inspiration for comedy because
all that you have to do is just read
headlines yes 100
100 i'm i'm so overwhelmed with how much
material there is
i'm almost like frozen on the spot it's
like my fight or flight is like
for comedy right now there's so much
it's weird right because you guys
haven't been able to do
much live stuff and everyone that's been
doing things on the internet
it's kind of made sense because it's all
internet stories and then internet
commentary
yep i think it's great because i started
doing the online stuff
five probably six years ago and all my
stand-up friends were making fun of me
they were like that's not real comedy
that's not and then they were all forced
to do it during the pandemic
and now they get it and they get how fun
it is and they get that we can reach a
bigger audience
so that was their first time and now you
have endless content
yeah yeah it's mental it really is i
guess because in the uk
we see some of the stuff that trickles
through from america right
and i don't know it's it must feel like
every single day there's far too much
for you to even comment on
there is that's why i have to stop and
focus
myself and go okay wait what projects am
i actually working on because i can go
on twitter and be there all day
and just make fun of these headlines or
make tick tocks or make whatever it is
so i have to i have to focus myself
here's something morgan's board right
now of comedy
yeah well the world is something that i
realized
a couple of weeks ago because i listened
to a good bit of the daily wire and i
mates with some of the producers there
which i know you're in nashville right
that's their hometown
now for them and um it hasn't felt like
they've had to come up with anything to
talk about
for about a year like they're just
constantly being because people don't
like being called reactionaries
but when there's more stuff to react to
then there is stuff for you to talk
about
from your side do you understand it
really feels like the left
is kind of throwing everything they have
at the world and then the right is just
playing defense at the moment
uh i agree with you on that but i don't
think it's the right tactic personally
and i've had that discussion with some
of the people at daily wire
i actually feel like conservatives as a
whole right now
aren't necessarily playing the best game
that can be played
if we're cool to get into that um
yeah i don't think being on defense
constantly is smart at all you should be
on offense
and i think that we're leading by being
defensive which doesn't work
and if we want people on our team we
should stop shrieking
and screaming at people and telling
everyone how much they suck all day
every day
and be awesome [ __ ] people and then
they'll want to be part of what you're
part of
it's kind of like christians who are
wearing necklaces and
having bumper stickers but they're
[ __ ] in real life
if you're a bit more christ-like or like
a cool person then people will be like
yo what are you about and then you can
tell them about your religion
but i think conservatives right now like
the whole game needs to shift and maybe
it's new coaches need to come in maybe
it's new influencers
maybe it's someone like myself that
doesn't want to be shrieking and
screaming
all day and i don't think that's the
only representation of conservative
women or libertarian women
and uh i think we can be awesome and be
friends and work with liberals
and that's the way to bring people over
to our side is by being so awesome they
want to be on our team
and yeah those are my thoughts it's easy
though
right it's like the if you were picking
a fight with someone you would always
pick the easiest fight because you know
that it's going to make you look the
best
or if you're going to have a dance off
with somebody you'd pick the person that
was the worst answer
and i wouldn't i want the best i want to
beat the best but that's because you're
a cheerleader
so i think that's an unfair fight um but
my point is like it's
it's always just the easy everyone's
getting baited out right everybody on
the right is getting baited out with
stupid stories from the left
but it's causing the right to never make
any progress because it's constantly
just batting back
against what's coming from the other
side yes imagine we
stopped uh giving attention to their
stupidity
and just started making awesome [ __ ] how
about that
what would awesome [ __ ] look like oh
gosh tv
films movies music being
awesome and also being conservative uh
to me it's like likened to
even gay pride month which is going on
right now there's people who are like i
am gay and that's their personality
or you can just be awesome and be
amazing at what you do and talented and
a good human and also be gay
which will make a lot more people
comfortable with gay people if they
weren't
in the first place i just i really
really think
from a strategy point we're not doing it
right right now the right's not doing it
right but who am i to just observe from
the outside and step in newly
you are a new resident of nashville so i
think you've got just as much
just as much right as anyone else is
that the me me society what you just
said there
the mimi music site a little bit yeah
what is it for the people that aren't
initiated what is it
the mimi me society is the you have to
care about who i sleep with
you have to care about what pronouns i
want to call myself you have to care
where i want to put my dick where i all
of my personal things you have to care
about me
and make sure during your day that you
are acknowledging everything that i want
to be and be known for
and instead of just being a good human
like everyone's so obsessed not everyone
but so many people are so obsessed with
you have to call me this and you need to
care about who i'm sleeping with you
have to care about all my little
idiosyncrasies of my life no they don't
they don't have to care about you get
over it make cool [ __ ]
be a good person go out with your life
why do you think that people are
bothered about that now
give me a thesis on that my thesis is
it's easier to complain that you're not
getting attention for things that aren't
attention worthy than to make something
that deserves attention
yeah that's my thesis it's a lot harder
to create
amazing art and things of value
than it is to say why aren't you giving
me attention for who i put my dick in
you know i don't personally have a dick
but if i did
you'd be saying it um yeah i
read peeled michael knowles on this the
other day i would tell you the same
thing have you heard of the inner
citadel do you know what this is
okay so it is a way of looking at the
world
where when you fail to win a game you
decide to claim that the rules should
have been changed
so that they fit around what you can do
so if you can't
get what you want you have to teach
yourself to want
what you can get so for instance let's
say that um
you lose a leg or something you can try
and fix a leg and get it back on
and then if you can't fix the leg you
say that the desire for legs is
misguided
and that everybody else that wants legs
is completely wrong the point is
we see this with people who are
overweight perhaps
they struggle to lose weight and then
they'll say well
the entire world's idea of health and
body standards is completely
like misinterpreted or um we see this a
lot in
the sort of progressive psychedelic
culture
where someone will really struggle to
maintain a monogamous relationship
then declare that monogamous
relationships are for suckers anyway
so i'm gonna go polly yeah
is it that or is it just the fact that
you really struggle to
find someone that you can work with or
maybe you struggle to remain faithful to
somebody
so that's the retreat to the inner
citadel and it seems like it's with this
as well it's like look
i should be liked because i have talent
but i don't have talent therefore the
world doesn't like me because of
one of these particular grievances yes
exactly
yeah i think that's exactly what that
you're correct one thousand percent
that's exactly what's happening
and it's so easy isn't it to just not
actually do anything but complain
gosh that's an easy way to get a trophy
i am the greatest complainer on the
internet
all of you are doing life wrong you
should bow down to me and if you don't
do exactly what i want and you hurt my
feelings you're a bad person cancel you
haha i win like what a stupid game why
are we playing it with these people
like that's what brings me back to what
i think the right is doing wrong
why are we playing this game with these
people for what
there's no winning this game they're
going to keep moving the goal post
and it keeps getting stupider and
stupider as if that's a word
yes roll the clock forward then what
happens next
uh in my perfect world okay
in my perfect world conservatives and
libertarians would stop playing stupid
they would declare sure white flag you
guys win
we're horrible you're right all right
good luck
and then we will just make our own films
we will not cancel each other
no matter what because grace is a virtue
that i think we need to have more of
um even if someone says something
disgusting 10 years ago
we say hey that was kind of gross 10
years ago and then they go
oh yeah that was gross 10 years ago and
you go okay cool don't do that again
sweet
and then we move on and we
create culture we make films and art
and sports and we let sports be about
sport again
and not about kneeling or who pretends
to be woke but actually supports
communist china
lebron james you know we just bring
people back to being people and just
let them play their games and just laugh
at them like children having temper
tantrums because that's what they are
we're giving way too much effort to a
kid having a temper tantrum
when moms know when you start ignoring
that part if it's not
for a good reason if you just ignore it
they'll stop they'll cry themselves out
and they'll
okay i'm back to playing like yeah
have you seen in the uk at the moment
that the players taking
so it was an england game a couple of
days ago the players took a knee
for blm at the start the game the entire
stadium booed and then again yesterday
it happened and it was
really loud and they took the knee for
15 seconds
15 seconds of booing is really awkward
and the commentators don't know what to
say but yeah that's
that's the response in the uk at the
moment what's it is that happening in
the us i don't think so
not from what i've seen um they aren't
really doing it that much anymore
because they got booed so many times
from what i observed
okay um yeah i haven't seen that lately
but i saw the nba's ratings go
right on down i saw like i had a friend
actually compare my personal ratings to
nba ratings and i was beating the nba
multiple weeks in a row with views which
is ridiculous
when you think that's stupid what is
2021
um but yeah i haven't seen it that much
here but it's just stupid it's stupid at
this point
we all know blm is a stupid organization
where they have
kept most of the money there's so much
fraud within it of course black lives
matter that goes without saying
and if there's anything we can do to
help people rectify poor situations
let's do that
but taking a need does nothing let's
stop
the virtue signal off you know what i
mean it's like how many virtues can we
signal today that's the real sport now
it's just dumb well i don't know given
the fact that the country it originated
in
and the uh incident that sort of kicked
it all off
has had its years anniversary now if the
country that it started in has stopped
taking a knee
yep why why is the uk still
doing it because if you take a knee you
are so
important and you are better than
everyone who didn't take a knee i can't
believe you didn't know that
like you're not a good person for not
knowing that i am
by virtue a better person significantly
significantly better person yeah
but i mean there's there's all sorts of
stuff at the moment there's still
black lives matter um logos on the side
of the time bar
at the top of the the top of the score
on the
on the tv there's different pop-ups and
stuff that go on but there has to be a
point in which
that stops happening like it can't
happen for the right well i mean it
could happen for the rest of time but it
would be like you know
50 years so there has to be a point in
which it it does stop but apparently
not yet how about now i vote now
sky sports are you listening yeah guy
sports come on now
i have me i made videos about this while
it was going down
in the first uprising of blm and i do
feel like so many people have so many
valid points
obviously but i'm not
into complaining or putting on a show of
the virtue signal without having
ways to solve problems and that's just
the kind of person i am it gets me in
trouble i'm like okay how do we fix it
sometimes people just want to complain
but i'm like okay no but like how do we
fix it so we can move on
and these banners don't fix anything
it's a little back
pat a little acknowledgement but okay
things have gone
horribly wrong in these certain areas
what do you guys need
what do we do how do we help that's
that's all i care about anything else
i'm just like be quiet
well i guess as a player as well there's
going to be so much pressure
you're going to think oh god if i'm the
one that doesn't take any especially if
the rest of the team
are so you have this sort of crowd
mentality that's also creeping in there
that would be very strange because you
know that they would be the headline in
every newspaper
the next day the one person racist
player yeah
yeah for sure yeah it'd be great if it
was a black person who
did it wow that i think that would be
the change if one black
player didn't take the knee and they're
like this is dumb what are we doing
that's the ultimate red pill
uh have you spent any time in the uk
yes i love it so much i love you so much
i recorded a bunch of music there
um i've been i'd say to most of the hot
spots
so lots of time in london uh manchester
through there obviously
um the isle of wright was a music
festival i went to
which was so much fun and i got to see
rod stewart perform
and everyone knew how much i loved rod
stewart and it was a big deal
everyone just turned and looked at me
when he went on stage because i was
losing my [ __ ]
um and he was so good and you wouldn't
think that but he was amazing
um yeah i've been to a whole bunch of
different parts
in the uk and i freaking love it
canadians and brits are so similar in so
many ways
very similar sense of humor dry wit that
i love
um yeah i love me some costa cookies too
you guys have
such good cookies at costa like right
when i land i go to costa
like give me a cookie it's weird that
one of the things that we can beat
america and canada on is fast food or
like convenience foods but apparently
apparently we've got that down um yeah
yes
i think that the brits and the canadians
have a fair bit in common
do you think much about kind of
obviously you've got i guess cultural
leaders in the west
canada the uk and america do you ever
think about sort of the differences and
the the little quirks and the
the similarities between them oh yeah
um what i've noticed like being canadian
and then
moving to america is that there's so
much
fighting in america because they take
themselves too seriously
like individual people choose to be
offended
whereas a brit or a canadian would laugh
at the exact same thing
so you guys you know you take the piss
which i love that's why i love
people in the uk because you all take
the piss and it's so much fun
and the same as canada i was talking to
a friend the other day and we're like
we grew up different like we would mock
the crap out of each other
every day every different race every
ethnicity we're all in the same class
my friends were jamaican and from
trinidad and from everywhere and we
would make
racist jokes to each other's faces
they'd call me a honky or
a cracker or whatever and i'd laugh and
i grew up on the simpsons
and i feel like america somehow lost
that like they somehow lost the ability
to laugh at themselves
or a lot of americans did specifically
one group of people
um but yeah that i think is the
difference within it and
i do want us to bring that back i feel
like taking yourself too seriously
is a mental illness at this point like
just chill
you're not that important your feelings
aren't that important to everybody
and that's yeah that's what i think
happened
that's a really interesting one i was
having a chat with a buddy who's now
living in nashville
actually a couple of weeks ago and he
was saying he's a
british guy and he was we were talking
about the fact that as a young person
growing up in the uk if you do stuff
that's different if you decide that
you're going to move out to nashville to
start a business or
if you start acting or dancing or
modeling or drawing or poetry or
whatever
the piss taking can really nerf the
edges of your creativity
so it's great because people don't take
themselves too seriously but it also
dampens down a lot so you get tall poppy
syndrome
like very very badly in the uk
um especially because there's a lot of
manchester working class town
newcastle where i'm from working class
town perhaps a little bit less in london
because it's a bit more cosmopolitan and
people of the world and stuff
um but yeah the dark side of that of the
piss taking and not taking stuff too
seriously
is that you don't have the american you
can be whatever you want to be
gas your friends up the the support and
the yes
jimmy little jimmy you can go and do it
type thing i understand that
that causes in later life people to
feel like they're owed something and to
struggle when they don't get
success that they feel is deserved but
in earlier life definitely in the uk
both me and my buddies said
the tall poppy syndrome is pretty real
so i think that you need a balance of
the two what's it like in canada
i think that'd be fantastic to balance
those two
i think canada is
the politeness is a real thing so it is
yeah it is i actually think it's
cowardice at this point though
uh this is we can we can circle back to
that which point you want me to go on
those are two different roads where you
want me to go
first one okay we'll stay on the first
one
in canada it was uh yeah you can
do whatever you want if you go to
america
oh [ __ ] like that's how i grew up was
believing in the american dream
our culture our film our everything was
like
be whatever you want over the border
yeah go over the border you've made it
if you go to america
it was never you can make it in canada
ever like in music and entertainment and
anything
so it was yeah you do as much as you can
here
and then get out of here if you wanted
to export yourself how weird
yeah yeah that was the that was the
whole thing when i got my
us visa like my entertainment visa to
work
in america and be a legal immigrant it
was a big deal it was like a super proud
moment of my life
because i was like i did the thing now i
can start yeah exactly yeah
yeah what about the politeness
i've always prided myself on being a
polite canadian
and traveling to europe and across the
world and people knew i was canadian
before i said i was canadian and i loved
that but during the pandemic
i believe our politeness has equated to
cowardice
and every time we should have stood up
we didn't because we're being polite
every time the government told us
something that's absolute freaking
nonsense
we're still in lockdown in many places
in canada
we didn't stand up because no no we
don't want to cause trouble well no
that's being a coward that's not being
polite
and now that you've been a coward for a
year your businesses are gone
your friends businesses are gone your
kids are having mental health problems
all of these things crumbled around you
because you're being polite
it yeah i'm not in canada right now
because i'm quite certain i'd lead a
revolution and get arrested pretty quick
i swear i swear to you i would just have
none of it
a friend of mine yesterday she was on a
set working on a feature film
they found out that she had been in
america in a few weeks
since like before that rather and
she had an antibodies test and she did
have coveted antibodies
she had three coved tests all came back
negative
they surrounded her kicked her off set
and threatened to kick her out of the
actors union
because she had been in america weeks
prior
not because she has covid but she put
people at risk because she had been in
america
like that's just stupid you're being
stupid i don't know how to play that
i just i don't know how to play stupid
with these canadians right now
and every time i'm like stand up they're
like no we're good
is canada quite procedural because one
of the things that i see in the uk we're
quite orderly
we tend to if you look at the queue of
people outside they'll all stand there
sort of
in a relatively orderly manner i love to
queue you love it love it
i could just set up a queue anywhere and
you guys would just like for nothing
yeah i've always thought i've always
thought it'd be good if there was a q
appreciation society and people
literally queued up for nothing and then
high fived at the end i'm like that was
awesome we've got to go again
and then just go back to the queue and
then keep on doing that you can see that
i've been a club promoter for a long
time that i love cues
yeah cute i love that about you guys
that you love cues
um but canadians it was fantastic at the
beginning of covid that we were so
procedural because i was there
and i saw the mass chaos in america
people fighting over groceries and stuff
and then i went to our grocery stores
where everyone you didn't even have to
ask them
they were lined up perfectly spaced out
there was
a toilet paper display at the front with
a joke on it like don't worry we have
lots
there's classical music playing in the
grocery store to calm everyone down and
everyone's being extra polite
it was utopia but you know six months in
when we're realizing
covet isn't exactly what we were told
and i can't convince my friends
otherwise because procedure procedure
it's oh you can't think for yourself
that's a problem
that's a problem that's so interesting
because we think all of the stuff that
we're talking about here
something that's good or cool or
interesting has a dark side to it
on the other end right whether you're
talking about yes yeah precisely yeah
uh whether you're talking about the
orderliness of the uk and canada which
means that
at least in the beginning it gives you
more procedure but then on the other
side it makes you more compliant
or the fact that in the uk and candy you
don't take yourself too seriously but
you get tall poppy syndrome or in
america you get
it's like it's like people right there's
no one that you know that's got all of
their
attributes maxed out at 100. for every
100 that they've got they've got
something that compensates for it
oh for sure i think that's what's great
about people
and that's why i'm so against cancel
culture is oh
we expect everyone to be perfect to your
likeness of perfection
at all times got it imperfect person
got it like i i think of tweets for
example
that i wrote 10 years ago when i was on
painkillers hot like hardcore
painkillers
just to survive in nerve damage and
things
i tweeted crazy [ __ ] that i thought at
the time made sense
roseanne ball stuff oh probably roseanne
should have never been canceled that one
really pissed me off
um yeah she was on drugs and
she didn't know that the woman who looks
visibly white was black
that's a really strange reason to cancel
someone
uh but with myself when i was in a lot
of physical or emotional pain
i would post negative things and
sometimes it would have been the same as
i would have done in stand-up that it's
kind of like heckling
the crowd back or like poking fun at the
crowd but i couldn't do that so i'd do
it on twitter
and out of context you can take anything
out of context
and then label someone a horrible human
being so i just think it's
it's just stupid and it's for people who
completely lack grace or humanity to be
trying to cancel people
over anything my thoughts you had this
huge back injury which is where that
chronic pain for a long time
came from can you tell us that story
sure um 2008
i was in the middle of shooting a
feature film my first thought i was
a larger role in and i had a whole bunch
of other ones booked
and my one night off went to go do some
karaoke
got out of a taxi and we were rear-ended
as i was halfway out of the cab so
my body was completely twisted i was
halfway getting out crossing my legs
like a lady
and we got hit pretty hard from behind
which meant
that my spine jutted into my nerves
all the way down because i was twisted
and head injury
neck injuries tmj so bad i what's tmg
uh the the joint in here
like the jaw pain where you clench so
bad because you're in a lot of pain
or i don't know the exact word of it
everyone's tmj
but it's it's the jaw thing so basically
while i was sleeping i was in so much
nerve pain and chronic pain that i was
cracking my own teeth in my sleep and
swallowing them
i know disgusting yeah i would wake up
missing teeth it was yeah bodies are
strange um my s i joint like near your
hips
it was crooked lower back pain was the
worst
because it shot down my feet and into my
legs
and when you combine all of those things
together and then from the neck it
shoots down your arms so i claw hands
for a long time
uh when you combine all of that plus the
cognitive issues i had from the head
injury it was
disaster for almost a decade and
i struggled to live and then i struggled
to work
i struggled to communicate and then
eventually i ended up on disability
living at my grandma's house on the
floor and that's where i spent a good
part of seven years
which is crazy because i lost a lot of
my life
and i smile when i say this story now
because i do think it's the best thing
that ever happened to me
um because i learned so much about
getting back
up and i know that it's my legacy now is
that i went through
all of that and wanting to commit
suicide not because i didn't want to
keep going but because of the actual
physical chronic pain it's maddening
i wouldn't wish it on my worst enemy
nerve pain
is maddening waking up not knowing my
address
not knowing where a purse why my purse
is in the fridge
or just all it's a trip it's a trip when
you have a head injury that bad that
you're in your head
and you know you have a head injury like
my real voice was in there and i'm like
nicole you're not okay that's [ __ ] up
you just put your purse in the fridge
you're you have a head injury
but then i couldn't function um
but i went through all these things and
i feel like i just had the last step in
all of it recently because i had a
surgery
to remove the scar tissue from around my
back
and i felt like a different person
on that surgery table and i had one of
those weird
surgery moments that people talk about
where
i could just like feel the trauma coming
off me
and it was very interesting i
decided to stay awake at the last second
and i was supposed to be put out and i
literally at the last second i was like
you know i think i want to stay awake
and they'll just
they orally sedated me instead and
i didn't watch what they were doing
because that's gross but
the doctor was like such a happy person
and the nurses were happy and they were
playing like
rock music and pop music like super loud
while they're operating
and just watching these really happy
people that love their job
take this stuff out of me i just felt
like i was finally closing a chapter and
i could
literally feel it coming off of me
and i swear i could hear god i don't
know what you believe in
but i could hear god be like okay here
you go let's go
i was like oh [ __ ] it's go time
how many procedures have you had then
since the accident
that was my only operation because i
said no to all of them so
because i knew that the downtime would
be bananas
so i did things like like every
treatment you can think of that wasn't
surgery
i have done well and i mean all of it uh
everything from like
physio to nerve block injections which i
really think saved my life
nerve blocks have you ever done them um
for those of you who don't know they
take a needle hopefully the one from
japan because it's thin
it's about this long and they inject you
throughout your nerves
with the same stuff that they put in
your teeth at the dentist to freeze you
so it's super painful to get it done and
you probably go into there's a good
chance you go into shock i went to shock
multiple times after it was done they
can't sedate you sufficiently
stop you from being able to feel that
well i'm awake
when they do it so you're usually awake
when you do it i had to do it so often
i don't know that's just the way they
did it okay because yeah i don't know i
didn't
even get the option no one in this
clinic got the option of going under
but i'd go into this clinic they'd be
like are you ready for this i'm like
let's go it's like an x-men hospital and
they would inject me throughout my body
and in my jaw and my neck and down my
back and stuff uh it was every three
months for
quite a while closer together at the
beginning and then it would
last a bit longer a bit longer but i had
to mentally prepare to okay your body
might go into shock get ready
what's sh what happens when you go into
shock you start shaking
uncontrollably my jaw would chatter um
like your whole body could convulse they
have to strap you to the gurney type of
thing
but it's just because you hit a level of
physical pain that your body is just
like we're tapping out
and then i i think it like took me
to a different level of consciousness
actually
where i just interpret things
differently now and i wrote one full
song that's going to come out soon
while that was happening i wrote the
whole thing in my head i saw the music
video
and it's going to come out soon it was
kind of cool
[ __ ] the bed okay so you're going
through this
you managed to get yourself to the stage
where what halfway through
you enable there's no sort of future
ahead you don't think that you're going
to get any better
thank you for leading me in this story
because i'm really awful at telling it
because there's so many details um i got
to the point where
the doctors gave me a disability
certificate for life
which is especially in canada no i
ripped it up
i ripped it up that day that i got
pissed uh it might be somewhere in my
like in my documents but i ripped it up
that's a pretty possibility
thanks like that was my moment of [ __ ]
this
[ __ ] no and i'm gonna get better and
they told me like it's really hard to
get a disability
certificate in canada which means the
government's going to pay you for life
to live because they don't believe you
can have meaningful employment
or do it consistently and when i got
that i just
i lost my [ __ ] and i just went no this
is not
this is not my life this is not the end
of my life and
i took myself to a bookstore with the
tiny little bit of money that i had that
i scraped from
inside of a couch and changed from my
purses
and i bought a louise hay book which
i had never heard of louise hay and i
just went you can heal your life okay
let's try that and i got another louise
hay book
and a little candle and i just went on
this crazy journey of
extreme positivity i put sticky notes
all over my entire house
that were like you can do it you look
better every day
your nerves are healing uh you're
amazing
everywhere i could see them so every
time i'd have a negative thought it
would be automatically countered
and it works um i remembered that i'm a
cheerleader which i know you've seen a
bit of my talk on that
is i wasn't a model anymore because i
couldn't model i couldn't do acting i
couldn't do any of the things that i'd
known myself to be
my whole life but i'm a cheerleader and
that has nothing to do with my palms or
dancing or anything
that's who i [ __ ] am and when i
remembered that
i was like let's go biggest cheer in my
life
and i started literally cheering myself
back to life
and prepped myself that there will be
bad days for every good day i'd have i'd
have
five to ten bad days and i'm ready for
it
and i would have charts and i would give
myself ticks
for good things that i would do and okay
you did physio and you didn't pass out
after
yeah you did and i took out all the
negativity i stopped watching the news
no horror movies no csi no negative
podcasts
none of it cut it all out flooded myself
with
motivation positivity inspiration tons
of sermons every single day which i
still do
and it started to work and i did all the
alternative therapies but
it was a mindset shift that i will not
also this is so important for people
i fired and i say fired because i
believe you hire and fire your medical
team i fired every doctor who said i
wouldn't get better
and i was like you're wrong and then i
left
and i only had people on my medical team
who believed i could get better and who
were supporting me in that journey
and i think we all need to do that and i
think doctors who tell people they won't
get better need to
not be doctors anymore because it's a
really big mental challenge
to overcome when you hear it from a
medical professional
and having a team around me that were
like okay
will you do this i went on a strict
alkaline diet like yep let's do it
inflammation went down i started with
all different kinds of supplements to
help with my mind healing
i stopped looking at screens a lot
during the day because my mind
literally my brain needed to heal i did
everything i had to do and now i'm back
and
yeah having gone through that like
i'm fire proof i walked through the fire
so i know we were maybe gonna talk about
this but when i get haters online
it can hurt my feels my little girl
feels for a second
but i'm like [ __ ] i've been through
real pain this
ain't it like this is not real pain i
have been in shock
i have crushed my own teeth you sang
fake untrue things about me to try and
hurt my career because you see me as a
competitor
does not do it you will not stop me and
i think it's
kind of cool that i've been through that
and i can help other people get through
their [ __ ] now because
you can do it it's one of the best ways
to transcend suffering right you do you
go through something it's terrible
it's awful and then you realize hang in
a second that's now
set the bar for whatever anything in
future this is what i say to people that
suffer with depression
like look if you've been really really
badly depressed and you've been
the architect of your own misery right
if you've been your own torturer
you can walk out into the world and be
essentially bulletproof
because what's your boss going to be
able to say to you that you haven't said
to you
a million times better i just hit my
head on the thing because there's a clip
in my hair
um that's exactly what i say i'm glad
that was fun for you
um that's exactly what i say it's like
nobody
on the internet in the world and
anything can say something to me that i
haven't said to myself already
i've said it all i believed it too i
laid on the ground for years
in that hole on a carpet that smelt like
cat pee and i was like oh this is my
life now
nope you got nothing you got nothing on
me
so i think it's such a freaking
superpower when people
will take that moment and harness that
superpower
just harness i think depression is such
a freaking gift
if you can switch your mindset and look
at it because
when you pull yourself through it and i
believe everybody can
i really do then you're set you're set
you can always go back to that and be
like oh yeah i remember when i overcame
that huge thing
this is nothing do you find it hard now
to connect with people because of what
you've been through
so your world view is changed quite
profoundly right you go through this
very extreme intense experience and then
out the other side of that
you have to try and speak to people
who haven't been through that who
haven't haven't been through something
analogous to that right their own
version of self work and discomfort and
stuff like that
does it sometimes feel like you're
talking on
different levels some of the times that
i see you talking to people
or some of the comments that i see you
making online and some of the videos
i appreciate some of the places that
you're coming from and i also appreciate
why
other people don't necessarily get it
yeah
uh my mind went in three places on that
answer too
so first one is i believe
on this playing field we call the earth
we're
in different grades and it's just like
school
and some people come here and this time
around you're in kindergarten
and that's cool they're generally happy
the their
their spirits are good they're the last
ones at the bar they're drunk as [ __ ]
they're falling over they're happy
people they're fun to be around
there's some people who are coming here
and they're in grade eight and there's
some people who come here and we're
going to be in university we're we're
going through all the grades
for me to be in university and be mad at
someone in grade
6 not understanding me talking about
algebra is stupid on my part
will i try and communicate as best as i
can to reach as many people as i can
yes but i can't reach everybody and i'm
okay with that i'll do
i'll do my best maybe they'll like one
of my dance videos and that will inspire
them because they know i've had a hurt
back but now i'm dancing
but i don't uh i don't try and tailor
myself to reach everybody because i
don't think that's authentic
and i'm not mad at people who don't get
it i'm genuinely not mad
and then when it comes to uh you know
what we were just saying uh sorry go
back to i you triggered something
connecting so when you're connecting
with people yeah and you sometimes
struggle it got me in trouble actually
so
i woke up one day and i was like
okay i'm gonna start making these videos
i'm gonna start saying all the things
that when i thought i was going to be
dead
or or commit suicide that i wish the
world
knew that the things that we fight about
the things that we lie about which i
think is the number one
problem in life and in the world is we
lie constantly
and then we get mad at our at the
results of our own lives
i'm just gonna tell the truth and i'm
gonna tell it over and over and over on
all these different topics back to
freaking back to back
i make it funny so it's more palatable
and because that's what i do
and i made my plan and i started making
these videos
and they hit viral viral viral i knew
they would too
but march of 2014 i believe it was
i took myself off disability against the
doctor's orders i'm like
don't send me a check i'm not disabled
anymore thank you very much
and then by september i was the most
viral comedian in history
so i had a major culture shock
suddenly being back in the world i
hadn't been out of the house
in a very long time and then suddenly i
was on the view
and suddenly i was at the royal palace
performing like a private event so that
was
like super culture shock for me so that
was one thing that aside
i've gotten i'm gonna stay in trouble a
lot in the last few years because
i automatic i can see everybody
suffering i can see it
i have a radar for it now they don't
have to tell me i can feel it
um a guy recently was like
he's going for a run and he's running
this much today and running this much
today and i'm like
so what are you running to or from i
haven't decided and he was just like
he knew i knew and i always know and
i've been around
some gents in the last few years i'm
gonna say this as politely as i can
where they had some pretty big issues
that they were going through and my
automatic reaction was to say it's okay
i'll love you as a person anyway and it
bit me in the ass so hard every single
time
because i'd hang around people that i
probably shouldn't have been around
because i didn't want them to feel alone
because i had felt alone when i went
through stuff
when really those people weren't in line
morally or in integrity
with who i am and what i want to be
about but i just didn't want them to
feel what i felt
so it got me in a lot of trouble that's
a really interesting insight i think
if you've been through dark places
depression or injury or
whatever yeah and you've come out the
other side
you that hero story inside of yourself
is something that you want to
see or inspire or initiate in other
people
yes and that gives you
faith unwarranted faith sometimes
that other people are going to be able
to reenact
that particular story you're 100
correct and actually this is something
that it first sparked
when i was speaking with jordan peterson
i went i was trying to like think of
some things i've had
issues with dating and different stuff
like that and
that's really what it boils down to good
in people that isn't there
yeah yes 100 and
refusing to be nasty in the face of
nastiness
it it can get me walked on and i'm not
doing it anymore
but that's exactly what it was i saw the
good in people that was not there
because i
i hoped it was there and i believe it
probably was there at some point
and then it the world knocked it out of
them but i can't save everybody
that's not my job my job is to lead ah
conservatives libertarians listen to
this part my job is to lead in the
direction that i would like the world to
go
and those who want to follow me will
come with me that's what i'm gonna do
now
talking about the fact that you were
you'd lost
probably most of the things that you
valued as a human right so your
cognitive capacity which was your
uh cognitive nimbleness your agility
your ability to come up with
funny things and speech your looks as a
young girl who was
cheerleading and modeling and dancing
looks body all of that sort of stuff
has that reframed the way that you
see sort of physical beauty now do you
judge
physical attractiveness in a different
way in yourself and in other people
yes and this is not a feel bad for me
but i'll explain the odd little spot
that i'm in
is that the way that i look is such a
juxtaposition
to who i am and what people expect me to
be based on the way i look
that it can kind of get tough like
when it comes to dating or friends or
anything is you know people might assume
i'm going to be a [ __ ] or i'm so i care
so much about these external things like
makeup in here is fun but i really don't
care
like i i care about people and i love
people and i want to hang out
and just be chill and put like i told
you put on a baseball hat and go to the
bar
um so that i actually think
made it very different for me because i
was so superficial before i
admittedly i was superficial af i bought
into all of it i thought this is what
i'm supposed to be like look like
i fell into it a little bit in la again
when i started to do well because
i'd spend eight hours getting ready to
go to some award show
and i'm like that was a waste of my day
like for what
i don't need to get my hair and makeup
done by this top person and sit there
for five hours
i don't give a crap put my hair in a bun
sure do my makeup lovely
this dress awesome thank you beautiful
design but i don't
care i don't want to be at the opening
of every envelope to pretend i'm special
i i don't care i want to make cool [ __ ]
so
it did change me in that way and i don't
no i don't think i know i'll never go
back because the things that people
care about a lot or we've been taught to
care about like
superficial beauty and money just for
having money not for the
using it as a tool that it is uh
like things objects i don't care
and i and it's hard to convince other
people otherwise when they've been kind
of brainwashed into
putting their value with the value of
the things that they have
the juxtaposition is an interesting
insight right so i did
reality tv i was on the first season of
love island here in the uk and uh club
promoter and blue tick on twitter and
feed charcoal toothpaste and all that
sort of stuff
um and still
now people that watch me on love island
don't understand
what i do my podcast about and think
that it's a gossip channel and then
people that know that i've done the
podcast don't believe that i was on love
island
so it's so bizarre how people are how
dare you
i well yeah i know like how could you
not be the person that you were four
years ago
yeah it's so weird how people rely on
archetypes
right so we watch tv shows and the nerd
has glasses and the villain wears black
and the hero has big muscles
why do they do that it's so that they
can shortcut you having to understand
multiple things about someone
they're just this perfect pigeonhole
cliche
of a human you know one thing about them
and from that one thing you can
accurately extrapolate everything else
that there is to know about them
one of the problems that you come up
against is when you have somebody who's
been
an ex-model or done reality tv but now
wants to talk about whether
aliens are real or somebody that used to
be achieving they're already here
well we'll wait and see this 60 minute
thing needs to finish up first
uh i was somebody that used to be a
cheerleader and now wants to talk about
politics it is that contradiction
is interesting to some people but it
it's off-putting to others as well
it is but are we going to shrink
that's not fun i i was shrunk for most
of my life
and admittedly i have shrunk
again multiple times since my car
accident even getting better
because i i was like oh i'm being too
much or i have agents or managers or
whatever be like
you can't be this plus this plus this
plus this well guess what i [ __ ] am
guess what i'm releasing music and it
sounds like lincoln park and
my other music i rap and it sounds more
like a gwen stefani type of thing
and i do comedy and i'm gonna talk about
politics and if you can't handle a
well-rounded person that's probably a
reflection of you
not me so whatever like we're on this
ride why aren't we gonna ride it
everybody should do that i've been
shrinking and i don't want to do it
anymore it's not
fun i think that's why we get depressed
too is we're trying to fit into these
little shells of humans that were told
to be
and they were like oh why am i depressed
just because you're not being you
[ __ ] that's why
it's like pretty easy i think you're
right you were talking earlier on about
some of the criticism and feedback that
you get online
obviously both good and bad what are
some of the
lessons or insights or tools that you've
learned to be able to deal with that
feedback because it's something that you
care about right no matter how many uh
awful situations you've been through
when you put something out that you have
put some effort into and you get
criticism
you're going to notice it so how do you
deal with it
again two-fold answer first i would say
when i get criticism i go one is this
true
is is what they're saying about me is it
a criticism of what i do for a living or
is it a personal attack if it's a
personal attack
is it true no okay then i don't care
then this is a reflection of that human
not me um why would they be coming at me
oh they heard that i have my own show
coming out they think i'm gonna be a
competition they're trying to cut my
legs off
got it or like you know take out my my
credibility
i get it shady but i get it um
and then you know if it is true what
they're saying
then there's something for me to learn
within that and that's dope thank you
even if you said it in a dick way thank
you because
i grew up with hardcore gymnastics
coaches ballet teachers from russia
tough love is what i'm used to so that's
cool so
is it true or not and then you decide
from there um
when it comes to criticism of my art
you're more than welcome to
sure yeah i know that the loudest booze
do come from the cheap seats so that's
one thing
but if you don't like what i do that's
cool go find someone that you do like it
doesn't
bother me because i like what i'm doing
and everything i do
isn't gonna be the best thing i've ever
done and that's okay too
uh beethoven's first song probably
wasn't that great
that's okay we only talk about the hits
you know
so i had a video a couple years back uh
this is america
and i redid donald glover's this is
america
i did my own like parody but really just
like a different version of it
i was like whoa what would it look like
to take this exact thing
pivot it this way about women people
lost their [ __ ]
they were like that's racist you're
taking away from the message of this is
america
there was all this crazy negative press
about me tmz of all people came in and
like rescued me and they were like she's
not
racist she just made a video and we
don't like it whatever thanks tmz
you know like of all the people who came
to help it was tmz which i thought was
freaking cool of them
um they've actually done that a couple
times over the years uh
but then i and i started to take it in i
started being like oh my god
i did a bad thing i was racist i'm
whatever what and i talked to black
people i literally
went up to strangers in restaurants i'm
like hey can i ask you a question group
of black people
hi i'm nicole would this is this
offensive to you
i made a remix of this song and they
were like no
i'm like all right cool and then i went
and i literally
surveyed random black people in la
because this is the kind of person i am
and nobody said it was offensive one
person was like oh i see how maybe
people could get upset because it's
about the history
of black people in america they're like
it was probably just too soon
turns out they were right it was just
too soon
hundreds of other remixes and parodies
came out
so many that billboard made a list of
the top 10
remakes of this is america but did you
they didn't put me on the list i was the
only female who did it
i was the first person who did it and i
had the most views on my video
and i took all the heat wasn't even on
the list
yeah oh but this is this place is okay
this is this thing is okay
should the song have been mixed properly
heck yeah the song was trash
but the idea was freaking genius and the
video
quality was great so yeah i learned some
lessons from it but what i really
learned was
i've been ahead of the curve a bunch of
times and then i take all the heat for
it
and then other people come in after and
whatever so that's an interesting thing
as well first mover advantage doesn't
really exist in the content creation
industry
almost anyone that i know that's in
content creation doesn't care about
being
first because the person that's going to
be first will make a ton of mistakes and
then
fourth maybe or fifth you can iterate on
that
make a few adjustments let the first
person trailblaze catch
yeah maybe that first person will get a
little bit more press attention
but their content quality is going to be
so much lower than yours and then when
you can come in and make it
no one cares about the fact that an lg
phone has a
bigger megapixel camera because apple
comes in and they do it
right they don't do it first they just
do it best
right yes another thing to do with um
people getting you allowing criticism to
bounce off you
because you're doing something that you
really truly enjoy
i think that one of the reasons that
some people get triggered by criticism
is when they're doing something that
they know isn't their true calling when
they're
trying to be somebody that they're not
yeah their concern is
[ __ ] i've put so much energy into this
persona
and it's not working like i i
i'm preaching yo that's true
that's just that's facts yeah well they
do all of this work and it's like an
easter egg right you wrap it around but
it's hollow in the middle you hit it
with a little bit of pressure and it
breaks
so that's why i think the people that
you can tell that are
in jordan peterson language speaking
their logos forward right they're being
the true selves speaking the truth when
they're doing something that truly is
them
it's like okay so the foundations of
that are always going to be deeper
than you pretending someone else trying
to be nicolab or someone else trying to
be chris williamson
that's just that's never going to feel
as
strong or as stable as just doing what
you're supposed to do
exactly which is why when i do get
criticism and i get it today i'll get it
tomorrow i'll get it in five years from
now it's fine
when i get criticism i go all right
what do you think i'm going to shrink
i'm not going to shrink and stop being
me
i'm just going to shine brighter every
time it's all like i feel like the more
punches i take the more
more hits i know how to take and then i
just go into the world and i shine
brighter because if someone says
something negative about me like oh
she's a mean person or she's a [ __ ] or
whatever
the way that i live my life will be
proving that differently
so i don't worry about it eventually
those people will see me
as who i am so i don't care if they
don't like my content that's a different
story and i wish you all and find
someone that you love because life's too
short to watch [ __ ] you don't like
um but it just it really doesn't need to
bother you
but what i think people forget and i'm
actually writing about this in my book
right now is that
there's gonna be haters it's gonna
happen
it's it's not possible for it not to
happen
and the greater the risk that you're
taking in your content in your life in
who you declare yourself to be publicly
the more
hate there will be period and that's
just the formula has nothing to do with
you
so stop being so egotistical take
yourself out of the equation
this is life [ __ ] get over it and
that's it and then you can deal with it
when you know it's going to come it's
just like your muscles are going to hurt
after a workout
you're building muscle so you know it's
going to come
deal with it you don't cry and quit
because your muscles hurt after a
workout
give it a couple days go again how much
is your team
professionally and your friends around
you how much are they
a buttress to assist you with
periods of low motivation and dealing
with criticism and stuff like that
there are a very tight crew
around me like a very very select few i
would actually say danielle delgado i'm
not sure if you know her
uh she is freaking incredible she's
known as the millionaire maker
she takes businesses from zero to a
million like like freaking that
uh really good friend of mine and she if
i do have a low period
or i can just call her and she gets me
back in five minutes um
tim grover has cheered for me multiple
times
in amazingly different ways in a way
that only tim grover can
i'm talking like a single sentence text
where it's kind of like
a it's a [ __ ] slap it's like
you know like kind of like are you gonna
give up and i'm like [ __ ] find him you
know like
okay like he'll he'll be you know he'll
be like step on their throats i'm like
you're right let's go
uh there's a couple select people that
are in my tight type personal crew too
but i find that i'm mostly having to
cheer the other people up around me
and i get a lot of guilt when there's
hate at me
um i feel guilty for the people around
me because i can see it hurts them and
they can't take
the hits the way that i can because they
haven't been in the ring training the
way that i have
so you know even in dating like
throughout
being famous famish whatever you want to
call it
um i feel like i've had to console
people that i've dated
when other people say negative things
about me because it hurts their feelings
because they know who i am and they're
like hey that's not whatever but
they can't spend their whole day proving
wrong and i'm just like it's okay
don't worry like it's okay i'm really
sorry that this hurts you
i'm gonna step away so that you don't
feel this because i can see
it affects you and yeah
that's that's kind of how i deal with it
what lessons do you wish you'd known
about dating a few years ago
it's different for me because of what i
do for a living but
i wish if i were much younger i would
have focused more
on my career first i spent a lot of time
when i think about it like dating lots
of guys because like that's what was
cool like nicole how many guys are you
dating or whatever
what a waste of time i got some good
material but what a waste of time
and i would say now
i wish i could tell i guess i can right
now
i wish i could tell guys and girls that
when you date someone
and it doesn't work out like if you're
looking for an actual partner
you have to move on i see every day like
this is like a nicole
observation of pain with my little that
i have now
it really hurts people that people have
a trail of everyone they've banged
in the last five years behind them only
like one step behind them
and it's like you're introducing the new
girl that you're dating to
30 other girls you hooked up with in the
last year
what are you doing or you're liking all
the other girls bikini photos that
you've been hooking up with the last few
years
what do you think that's going to do to
your current or future relationship
and it's not about jealousy it's about
integrity and romance
and fostering something new like that
didn't work
let it go you don't have to hate them
but you're spoiling
everything else you're putting mold on
the new bread what are you doing
how much of that taste every day how
much of that do you think is just
guys and girls being pricks in their 20s
though because i see
a lot of people hit 30s
and this ego game in relationships tends
to drop away
hormones are a hell of a [ __ ] drug
right
so true um i feel like it's being
i think it's getting worse actually
because it's being being toxic
is being promoted as like cool and
trendy and i don't know if you see it
it's clapping
yeah clap back fall over tick tock oh
i'm gonna bang all his friends because
he
like this girl's photo or he whatever or
like always have a side dick
always have a side chick like just in
case they screw up
it's promoted as like cool in culture
now
it's not cool i don't think degrading
other people is cool i don't think
making someone feel unspecial
is cool that's the opposite of what
we're supposed to be doing here
sure there's that you know that thing we
all go through the hormone raging
whatevs
but as you're moving on in life it's not
cool to not be cool to people
i don't like it and we really
again the way to combat it is with our
actual efforts and to show
healthy relationships and to show um
you know being a good person and having
a good relationship is okay
and that's cool too and you're allowed
to have fights and you're allowed to
have disagreements and you're allowed to
move forward together
and you don't have to have a big blow up
every time and
that's that's what i think there's a
thought experiment that brett weinstein
did with heather hayne on rogan a couple
of years ago
and he said can you imagine someone who
is hot
but not beautiful and then can you
imagine
someone that is beautiful but not hot
and the distinction between the two is
what we signal on when we're younger
we signal of hotness right with the very
easy to observe
signals of fitness adaptive evolutionary
fitness right
but beauty is something that's timeless
it doesn't wane with age it actually
increases with age it's grace it's poise
it's loyalty it's kindness it's peace
it's so on and so forth
and that actually can manifest in the
way that people move you can see the
girls
here's one for you any girl that wears a
one of those kind of like suit jacket
things that they wear on nights out over
the top of a dress
but without their arms in the sleeves
every single one of them
is going to start a fight every single
one of them is a [ __ ] so yeah
that's a signal that's a signal
oh my gosh that's a great observation
you're
right wow you stand on a lot of
nightclub doors you see
things like this so yeah stuff like that
right you see people in the way that
they hold themselves
in the way that they move you know i can
tell something about you
outwardly reflects something that is
emerging from you inwardly
and um yet that beauty and hotness thing
i often think people just get that
backward
and i understand like you know i went
through my 20s i
made the mistakes but i've seen you in
your bikini photos too
yeah yeah um but
my point is that the sooner that you can
realize i need to signal off of beauty
not hotness
the quicker i think you're going to find
yourself into a relationship and a
situation
with friends as well right yeah it's not
the friend that's got the fastest car or
the most money it's the friend that's
going to be there for you when you need
them and if they've got a fast car then
sick
yeah exactly i had that revelation as
well
as i started to do well because i had
all these people around me they were so
rich i was at their mansions they always
cool things and they're pieces of [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] and they hate their
lives and they cheat on their wives and
husbands
and they're not happy internally and
they're popping
painkillers and antidepressants and i'm
like why do you think you're doing that
uh because you're full of [ __ ] and
none of it mattered and i went i don't
care about your house or
your cars or your whatever are you a
dope person am i
comfortable around you like genuinely
because you get that little weird
uncomfortable feeling around some people
and i don't care how many famous friends
you have if i'm uncomfortable around you
i don't want to be around you
i want nice human beings yeah beautiful
people nikolabe ladies and gentlemen why
should people go they want to check out
your stuff
i would love them to go to instagram
letter i letter b
nicole arbour i'm i being nicole arbor
on tick tock
uh facebook what's the ib stand for well
like like abby nicole but actually
someone stole my name
i'm glad that makes you happy uh someone
stole my name years ago on instagram and
tried to sell it back to me
i can't remember it was like 20 or 30
thousand dollars and i'm like no out of
principal
i will start another account and i be
nicole
you be fake nicole so that's what that
was
i'm nicole over on twitter and i'm go
team everywhere if you if you're a
hashtag go team you'll find me
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy
peace